[Music]
in the u.s. there are about 2,500 child
fatalities annually due to abuse or
neglect by a parent or caregiver in
about half of those cases child welfare
agencies were aware of the neglect and
abuse beforehand how can these cases be
stopped from falling through the cracks
Allegheny County Pennsylvania might hold
the key they use predictive risk
modeling to target potentially dangerous
family situations and help vulnerable
kids before it's too late with
predictive risk modeling different arms
of local governments like schools
hospitals and welfare agencies collect
routine information about the kids they
see they share that information with
other agencies and that information gets
plugged into an algorithm and adds up to
a risk score these scores help child
service agencies identify which cases
need to be investigated most urgently
this isn't about seizing children from
their parents removing kids from their
homes is a last resort importantly
predictive risk modeling can help
determine which homes need assistance
from local agencies and prevent abuse
and neglect before they happen
if local governments are smart and
committed they can use this technology
to save kids lives how do you think we
can best prevent abuse and neglect among
children let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI